the Joe Rogan experience yeah what what
is currently a major focus for you hmm
well the repatriation and sacred sites
issue so returning cultural items and
ancestors back to their affiliated
tribes and is there a lot of that out
there so like I said there's that that
law the Native American graves
protection and repatriation act that
requires any institution that received
federal funding or federal agencies to
work towards a repatriation of items
that they've received over time back to
their tribes but there are also tons of
ancestors and items in international
museum so we're working on developing
strategies to go after those because a
lot of those countries they're there has
been kind of a rethinking about the
purpose of museums and and public
education regarding indigenous peoples
and how do we decolonize these
institutions and so we're trying to work
in some countries are easier than others
because if you have sacred religious
items from American indigenous societies
in some museums across the waters their
country considers it their cultural
property so you need an act of their
country's government in order to do
session those items and return them home
so there are some countries that are
much more difficult to work with than
others but we're in the process of
developing strategy to help internet
with international repatriation we're
also trying to watch private collectors
and educate people about the importance
of returning cultural patrimony and
other sacred items that they've received
over time whether or not there's a legal
obligation
there there's definitely an ethical and
moral obligation to return these items
so that that cultures can be revitalized
and that those items can be put back to
use so that's one one area we have a
repatriation conference every year that
we work together with tribes and
institutions and in foreign governments
to work on these issues sacred sites I
just was before the indigenous peoples
subcommittee in the house a few weeks
ago talking about what's going on at the
border and that autumn chairman was
there as well to talk about those issues
and as he spoke he was he was telling
the Congress representatives that he
just found out that they were blowing up
another section you know so it's it's
and that is happening because there was
a law in 2005 that allowed Department of
Homeland Security to waive all these
environmental laws and if there was an
emergency to do so and so the
administration is is saying that the
border wall is an emergency that allows
them to waive all these environmental
laws and so it's not just about
protecting sacred sites but all the
other environmental concerns all the the
animal migrations birds plants as and
water quality that are being affected by
this border wall because people strongly
think we need a 30 foot you know tall
border so so we're working we continue
to work to protect sacred sites so along
the border where where they're doing
this and putting in the wall many of
these areas have been designated as
sacred sites and so is that what's what
you're saying yes our known sacred sites
and there's artifacts there and all
sorts of different things that can be
destroyed by the construction age they
blew up an area and found human remains
oh Jesus mm-hmm yeah no do they stop
when they do that they were paid created
those bones and they kept going
yeah so this this is how that's it
that's it that's it they're just moving
forward they don't identify the bones do
you know for the rest of the culture
that might have existed no they're
moving forward and and you know what
they're saying and so and and the
rhetoric around this is so detrimental
because during during that hearing it
was clearly about how do we protect
sacred sites and and how do we make sure
that the tribal consultation and other
options can be presented so that that
environment and other areas are
protected and the Republican Congressmen
that was there it was really quite seems
like not a nice guy
basically said there is more damage
caused by migrant traffic trash and
defecating then there is by blowing up
the ground and so that is the Department
of Interior Homeland Security and and
Republicans in Congress are saying about
that border well just stop and think
about how that's unchallenged how
ridiculous a thing that is to say you
could pick up trash you can pick up [ __ ]
mm-hmm you can't pick up once you blow
up sacred sites yeah bones it's forever
and it's irreplaceable these are
irreplaceable resources the fact that
nobody challenged him on that like
that's such a ridiculous thing okay we
we challenged them and Deb Holland who
is a Native American
congresswoman definitely challenged him
about that but you know it's I think the
law is on their side is it safe to say
that there's many areas that you're
talking about along the border that are
probably undiscovered because you're
dealing with things that are potentially
thousands of years old
so remember undiscovered has different
meanings
so tribes may have understandings about
certain areas that other people do not
that they try to protect and so that's
why consultation is so important and
working with
so you can understand what's going on on
the ground but usually they do some kind
of minor investigation and supposedly
that was done that is being done but
nothing's being done to protect it so
it's known but so even if they consult
with the tribes and the tribe say this
is this area is essentially a burial
ground from a thousand years ago and our
ancestors use this yeah there you go
that's cool story we're gonna put a wall
here yep yeah but that happens that's
not just happening at the border that's
happening all over the United States
yeah yeah so and that's nothing new
what's new here is that all of those
environmental laws and those
opportunities for public comments so
it's not just tribal consultation but
even public comment have been completely
waived those stories always weird me out
when someone's building an apartment
building and they stop construction
because they found some sort of a burial
site underneath and you're like right
like how many of those are out there I
mean how many how many areas where
people are digging into the ground they
are gonna find some incredible
archaeological discovery and it's it's
getting you know smashed by a bulldozer
yeah it happens all the time I mean so a
lot of our a lot of the context for what
was happening here before Europeans came
is gone
yeah because we've just destroyed all
the evidence of it hmm
you know so that's why often the way
archaeological investigations have have
moved forward as they look at discrete
sites without connecting the dots in a
more holistic way about what's happened
in a certain area so all most of our
archaeological context and all that
evidence is gone and it continues to be
alluded by amateur archaeologists and of
course you know I've worked on many
different developments across the
country where you know the bulldozers
come Oh they see there's human remains
there and they just dump it into the
fill really yeah because they don't want
to stop the report plus money to stop
yeah across the show yeah
[Applause]